hey 42 here if I was to host a
hypothetical head-to-head tournament to
determine the most evil serial killer of
all time who do you think would win the
safe money would be on history's
homicidal Heavy Hitters Jack the Ripper
Ted Bundy Jeffrey Dahmer but if you had
to bet your entire life savings on just
one individual you could do a lot worse
than back the man often referred to as
America's first serial killer H.H Holmes
during a reign of sheer Terror in
Chicago in the late 19th century Holmes
has fought to a brutally murdered more
than 200 people at a rate of more than
40 per year many of his victims met
their maker in a house of death that
came to be known as the murder castle
built to a labyrinthim plan that only
Holmes himself understood the sprawling
complex was full of secret passages trap
doors and sound proofed torture chambers
Holmes lured hundreds of innocent people
to this morbid mansion with murder on
his mind and after killing them in the
most horrific ways imaginable some were
dissected others were stripped of their
flesh and sold to medical schools as
skeletons and still others were melted
in giant Vats of acid when you take into
account the volume and sheer brutality
of his crimes it's hard to imagine
anyone that can rival H.H Holmes for the
title of the most evil serial killer
ever to have lived but
the catch
he almost
knows nothing I've told you about H.H
home so far is actually true don't get
me wrong I didn't just make it up every
single detail the sky high body count
the castle of death the dissections and
torture chambers it's all a matter of
public record the staggeringly Gory
story is the subjective newspaper
articles encyclopedia entries and
multiple documentaries
which makes it all the more strange that
the entire thing is utter nonsense
this is the confusing tale of H.H Holmes
America's most misunderstood murderer
communication is crucial to building
strong relationships at work when I'm
coordinating my own team it's imperative
that I come across as confident and
capable and I'm sure it's the same for
you at your workplace that's where
grammarly comes in grammarly is a
digital writing assistant that helps 30
million people write more clearly and
effectively every single day it can help
to supercharge your productivity and
move your projects along writing is
literally my job and I spend most of my
week doing it and I've actually been
using grambly to sharpen how I sound for
a while now and honestly I love it I
especially like grammarly premiums tone
rewrite suggestions which can take your
writing to the next level I use
grammarly's confident framing feature to
help me transform my communication
grammarly turned what was a rather
uncertain sounding email into a strong
and confident one when the stakes are
high and time is short it's easy to
unintentionally come across as uncertain
or uncomfortable evident but with
grammarly you can make sure your message
comes across the way you intended the
right tone can move your projects
forward with the help of grammarly go to
grammarly.com
42 to sign up for an account and if
you'd like to level up your writing and
tone upgrade to grammarly premium for
twenty percent off thanks to grammarly
for sponsoring this video
Holmes was born under the rather less
enigmatic epithet of Hermann Webster
mudget on the 16th of May 1861 in the
town of Gilmanton New Hampshire almost
nothing is known about his early years
some sources claim he had an abusive
alcoholic father and that his favorite
childhood Pastime was to torture the
local Wildlife but those are just rumors
with no documented evidence mudget
married at the age of just 17 to the
first of what would eventually be four
wives though since he never bothered to
actually divorce any of them we can add
bigamy to his soon-to-be long list of
crimes budget was never a particularly
strong student but he managed to scrape
his way to a medical degree from the
University of Michigan and it was there
that we hear rumors of his earliest
crimes despite his reputation as one of
America's most notorious serial killers
much its first felonous forays didn't
involve creating cadavers but selling
them
in those days corpses were a
surprisingly valuable commodity sold on
the black market to medical schools for
anatomical research and budget was only
too happy to dig up the deceased from
the local cemeteries in order to make
some fast cash or at least that's what
several sources claim again there's no
real evidence to prove he was a body
snatcher but that probably shouldn't
come as much of a surprise I'm no
criminal mastermind but if I was in the
business of selling corpses I probably
wouldn't write receipts we do know that
body snatching was relatively
commonplace at the time and Michigan
University was a bit of a hot spot
there's also the probably not
coincidental fact that after his
execution some years later Holmes were
so worried someone might have come along
and dug up his remains that he asked to
be buried in a block of solid concrete
10 feet underground
so yeah there's a fair chance this
particular homes rumor is actually true
after graduating in 1884 mudgit worked
several odd jobs across America's
Northeast gaining a reputation as a bit
of a womanizer and a lot of a con man
two years later he moved to Chicago
where he restyled himself under the now
Infamous pseudonym of Dr Henry Howard
Holmes H.H Holmes to his mates most
historians agree the name change was
designed to stop the various people he'd
swindled from tracking him down but I'm
guessing he was also just a bit sick of
having a name like a squib from Harry
Potter according to the traditional Tale
on arriving in Chicago he found work at
a local pharmacy where he eventually
murdered his boss to seize control of
the business
in truth mudget well Holmes bought the
drugstore farron Square far from being
Holmes as victims to previous owners
outlived him by several decades a fact
that's proven by the dates on their
headstones which still survive to this
day
between the pharmacy and the growing
list of illegal activities Holmes was
fast becoming a wealthy man so he did
what any of us would do with a bit of
spare cash he bought an empty plot of
land and started work on a giant death
factory
we've all been there this Grand building
you see before you known today as the
Murder Castle was the result
now if you happen to be especially
observant you may have already noticed
at this Infamous Castle looks
suspiciously like a fairly standard
mixed-use commercial building and it
turns out there's a good reason for that
because that's exactly what it was there
were shops on the ground floor and
apartments above homes had a deferred
story in 1892 which he plans to use as a
hotel but it was never finished
in 1893 Chicago played host to a World's
fair a six-month Bonanza that attracted
a staggering 27 million visitors
probably the most famous element of the
commonly told hhm story is that he built
his Murder Castle to take advantage of
this huge influx of tourists in the era
before people posted 450 social media
updates every single minute tourists
were vulnerable their friends and
relatives often had little idea of
exactly where they were at any one time
so according to the story Holmes built
his murdery Mansion as a way of
ensnaring large numbers of hard to trace
World's Fair visitors preferably young
women ripe for murdering that all sounds
fairly logical well if you're a serial
killer but it turns out that Holmes
started building this Castle several
years before the Chicago Wolves Fair had
even been planned admittedly work on the
third floor did roughly coincide with
the announcement of the fair but we can
be fairly certain he didn't lure any
young women there for Netflix and
dismemberment because the hotel was
never actually finished
yes several people were indeed murdered
on the premises more on that in a minute
but the whole Murder Castle concept is
total nonsense the original
architectural plans for the building
don't show any secret passageways trap
doors or purpose-built torture chambers
and the building simply wasn't big
enough to have enclosed the complex
Labyrinth later accounts claimed almost
all these wild stories came from the
Press after Holmes was finally brought
to Justice a few years later it might
sound unlikely that journalists could
have gotten the details of the case so
incredibly wrong but Holmes's capture
happened to coincide with the Heyday of
what's now known as yellow journalism a
style of reporting where newspapers just
made everything up to sell more copies
why does that sound familiar
but whilst there's no evidence to
building with some kind of murder
Metropolis it was used as the base of
operations for a wide range of less
gruesome cons and schemes
deposit simply if HH Holmes believed
something could make him money he was
already doing it during his criminal
career he's known to have forged checks
stolen horses bought expensive items on
credit with no intention of ever paying
off the loans and defrauded a wide
variety of insurance firms in multiple
ingenious ways but whilst he wasn't the
mass murdering Maniac most people think
he was Holmes was still a killer and a
pretty prolific one at that we know for
sure that he murdered four people and
there's a good chance there were at
least nine victims the first is thought
to have been Julia Connor the wife of
one of home's employees Ned
Holmes and Julia started an affair in
the early 1890s and when Ned found out
he quite understandably quit his job and
moved away not long afterwards Julia and
her daughter Pearl went missing never to
be seen again we don't know for sure
what happened to them but Holmes later
claimed Julia had fallen pregnant and
that she died when he attempted to
perform an illegal abortion it's
generally assumed he killed Pearl
because she knew too much about the
circumstances of her mother's death and
therefore represented a dangerous loose
end Julia's remains were never found but
the body of a girl of about Pearl's age
was dug up in Holmes's Cellar after his
arrest five months after Julia and pearl
went missing Holmes struck again in
incredibly similar circumstances he
started a relationship with one of his
employees Emeline segrander before she
suddenly went missing once again Holmes
claimed a botched abortion was to blame
in retrospect that man probably
shouldn't have had a medical license
yeah the following year two more women
with ties to homes disappeared Minnie
and Nanny Williams as with all the
others the details are sketchy but it's
fought home scammed them out of some
property then murdered them before they
had a chance to go to the police much
like Julia Connor and Emmeline segrander
their bodies were never found there are
several more stories about people
turning up at Holmes's Castle never to
be seen again and several of them are
quite possibly true but convincing
evidence is extremely thin on the ground
and it's likely we'll never know for
sure how many people Holmes killed
though there's zero chance it was
anywhere near the commonly circulated
200. by 1894 he'd swindled and murdered
so many people in Chicago that he
decided it was probably best to move on
he traveled first to Fort Worth then St
Louis and it was there that the law
finally caught up with him considering
he was very probably a serial killer at
this point it's almost laughable that
Holmes was jailed for the heinous crime
of failing to pay off store credit
remarkably it was his first stint in
jail and whilst he didn't stay behind
bars for long his brief incarceration
kicked off a chain of events that Ward
eventually lead to him being hanged for
murder but I'm getting ahead of myself
whilst in jail Holmes met a man by the
name of Marion hedgepeth better known as
the handsome Bandit handsome hedgepeth
was a wild west Gunslinger who was
serving 25 years in The Slammer for
Train Robbery both being colossal
bastards Holmes and hedgepeth soon
struck up a friendship and between them
they cooked up a scam with a potentially
huge payoff
Holmes was going to fake his own death
if you're wondering how pretending to
die could possibly be a get rich quick
scheme I've got two words for you life
insurance Holmes was bailed not long
afterwards and he promptly put the plan
into action we don't know exactly how he
staged his own death but we do know the
insurance company became suspicious and
refused to pay out Holmes was undeterred
he knew he could pull off the scam if
only he could make things a little more
convincing but faking your own death
isn't like fighting Millennia in Elden
ring you can't just keep trying over and
over and over and over and over and over
again and that meant Holmes needed to
find someone else who was willing to
fake his own death in return for a slice
of the life insurance pie that man was
his longtime business associate and
literal partner in crime Benjamin
potezel and their plan was pretty simple
Step 1 take out a fat life insurance
policy in Benjamin's name
Step 2 get hold of a dead body of about
his size and build step 3 blow said body
up in a planned explosion making sure it
gets good and burnt in the process to
conceal its original features step 4
report the death step 5 profit the only
question was how to make sure the life
insurance company wouldn't see through
the ruse Holmes had already discovered
just how hard they were to fool but that
experience gave him an idea
what if he didn't have to fool them in
the first place
as you've probably already guessed
rather than risk using a random corpse
Holmes simply murdered Benjamin patezel
so he could make the claim for real
potasso's wife had been in on the scam
from the start she was the one who
needed to file a claim of the insurance
firm but she had no idea her husband had
been double-crossed she went through the
entire claims process including
identifying the charred remains of her
dearly beloved all whilst believing the
real potato was hiding out in London
somewhere if of course there is only so
long this deception could last sooner or
later Mrs Patel and her children were
going to want to see their father and
husband once again but Holmes wasn't
worried by this point in his career as a
professional he had plenty of
experience tying up Loose Ends along
with Benjamin to keep his secret safe
Holmes murdered free of the five
pietersal children two of the girls
Alice and Nelly were forced into a large
trunk which Holmes filled with
asphyxiating gas whilst one of the boys
Howard was poisoned dismembered and
burnt the potassium family killings are
the only homes murders we can be sure he
committed not only did he confess to the
crimes after his arrest he gave detailed
descriptions of how and where they took
place and he also told police where they
could find the remains thankfully those
were the final murders H.H Holmes would
ever have the chance to commit because
his old prison parlor handsome Bandit
had been doing some talking
it turns out Holmes had bragged about
all manner of evil Deeds whilst locked
up with handsome hedgepeth and the train
robber had decided to use that
information to buy himself a nice early
release he told the police everything he
knew about homes
Holmes was arrested in Boston on the
17th of November 1894. despite his
numerous crimes a relative lack of
evidence meant he was tried solely for
the murder of Benjamin potezel but that
alone was more than enough to see him
given the death sentence on the 7th of
May 1896 H.H Holmes was hanged when the
Trap was sprung his neck didn't break
and he was left twitching at the end of
the Rope for a full 20 minutes before
finally being pronounced dead as I've
already mentioned we have some Highly
Questionable 19th century journalism to
thank for many of the more outrageous
stories told about H.H Holmes today but
it's worth pointing out that Holmes
himself is responsible for much Fusion
before his death Holmes admitted to
killing 27 people the confession
delivered straight from the homicidal
horse's mouth should have been pretty
solid evidence but things were never
quite that simple when it came to homes
not only did Holmes's version of the
events contain several contradictions
and revisions he also claims to have
killed several people who turned out to
be very much still alive and several
others who were known to have died of
natural causes hundreds of miles away as
for what his motive was for confessing
to crimes he didn't commit your guess is
as good as mine some people believe he
was deliberately trying to Fan the
Flames of his own Legend before his
death whilst others think he was trying
to confuse the prosecution during the
trial I don't know perhaps he was just a
few sandwiches short of a picnic
even now almost 130 years after his
death mystery continues to swirl around
H.H Holmes along with the widespread
misinformation about his life and deeds
a decades-long conspiracy theory claimed
that Holmes didn't really die in 1896
instead according to the theory he
pulled off one last trademark scan
escaping his own execution by convincing
someone else to take the fall in his
place the rumor gained so much backing
that in 2017 his remains were exhumed
from their concrete tomb for examination
thankfully genetic testing proved
conclusively that the one thing HH
couldn't cheat was death
thanks for watching